[Musique]
sms on dirait le nom d'un virus
ça veut dire short message service le
service des messages courts pour
comprendre rien ne vaut les explications
d'une adepte chevronnés comme lucie tout
juste 18 ans mes trois années de
portables au compteur en fait les sms et
c'est tout simple on va dans la fonction
messages du portable on va d'en rédiger
message par exemple pour avoir le sait
on appuie trois fois sur les sur la
touche 2 ou par écriture intuitive en
fait on écrit qu'une seule fois la
lettre et et voilà par exemple pour
salut on fait comme ça hop vous
n'écrivez que les premiers caractères
c'est un logiciel avec 5000 mots en
mémoire qui devine est inscrit à votre
place le mot en entier l'uci ne peut
plus s'en passer
quand on est au téléphone on sait jamais
s'il maman on passe à côté de ma porte a
peut très bien coûter ma conversation
donc
donc c'est vrai pour ça le sms est mieux
puisque on peut enfin c'est plus discret
pour lui si la folie des sms semble bien
douce sauf quand tombe la facture comme
une piqûre de rappel regarde j'ai pas
regardé le numéro j'ai pas regardé j'ai
juste regardé à 10 me wade a peur mais
il n'y en a pas 93 euros voilà un peu
beaucoup
ces quarante sms au dessus du forfait
reçoit donc on a un vrai qu un code à
toutes les deux toi toi tu manges payer
le forfait totti peu la différence mais
d'accord sauf que là tu es ridicule là
parce que ça dépasse c'est complètement
stupide
ouais je déconne
les statistiques sont formelles ce sont
les filles qui utilisent le plus les sms
[Musique]
vous avez quel âge tu attends quelle
classe réel vous avez tout un portable
wii et qui paye la facture
et quand vous voyez vous le plus de
messages
wen lors à audrey emilie et les autres
formes grâce aux sms
une petite tribu ça resserre les liens
entre vous ça c'est clair
bah c'est grâce à ça que moi j'ai un
peut rencontrer audrey charlotte chili a
c'est un peu comme ça que tu essaies
rencontrer pour audrey est a répondu non
plus non mais attends a press kahlua
diffus portable ou problème l'autre
tribu celle des garçons n'arrête pas de
leur envoyer des messages
c'est par les sms que passent désormais
les premiers émois justin je t'aime et
bien ça fait toujours plaisir parce que
il l'a écrit la pensée à nous envoyer un
texto ça vous touche beaucoup ça le fait
qu'on vous envoie un petit message à
l'oral sms voici le code secret de leur
univers le mot de passe de leur liberté
loin des parents le sms ou service de
messages courts a explosé en un an on
est passé d'un million à 5 millions de
messages
on reçoit aujourd'hui des dizaines de
services par sms des messages de sa
banque des prévisions météo ou des
résultats de sport mais ce sont surtout
les jeunes qui se sont emparés de cette
nouvelle forme de communication
par exemple pour écrire demain on dit on
écrit un d eux
am est un donc pour prendre le moins de
place possible
donc c'est carrément un autre langage
que vous inventez battant tout le monde
s'écrit comme ça nos morceaux quoi
qu'elle court quand on prend des notes
on écrit comme ça c'est moins cher qu'on
appelle nouvelle communication nouveaux
marchés à 15 centimes d'euro par sms en
moyenne et le marché de la transmission
de données devrait poursuivre sa
croissance avec l'arrivée des nouveaux
téléphones portables pour ces
adolescents
c'est devenu un réflexe à la sortie des
cours taper un message sms sur le
clavier de son téléphone portable
un mode de communication simple rapide
et efficace pour rester connectés entre
copains ça coûte moins cher et puis un
petit extrait puis on n'a pas pu
recruter faut nous reste plus souvent
moi je suis autant obligé de l'an
dernier en france les moins de 25 ans se
sont échangées 6 milliards de messages
sms
un phénomène générationnel donc qui a vu
aussi l'émergence d'un nouveau langage
le par les textos à base d'abréviations
et de phonétique par exemple pour rire
on marque
mdr mort de rire mais bon voilà des
trucs comme ça mais sinon sinon c'est
chacun écrit comme il peut maintenant
les crèches voici quelques expressions
rédigé en langage texto ses adeptes
utilise également des signes de
ponctuation pour exprimer des émotions
ce qu'on appelle les smileys un langage
dont les codes sont parfaitement
assimilé par les ados au point de le
retrouver parfois à l'école dans
certaines copies à la fin pour des
rédactions mais toujours avec mais assez
au mieux de le mettre avec pourquoi on
met toujours pékin et les profs qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensent la langue française
serait elle en danger
pas pour phil marso en tout cas cet
écrivain a défrayé la chronique le mois
dernier en publiant un polar pour ados
entièrement rédigé en langage texto
quand j'étais môme j'étais très
complexée par rapport à 20 disait je
serai moins que rien tout ça donc c'est
quelque part c'est la revanche du camp
une provocation que le journal le figaro
n'a guère apprécié allant jusqu'à parler
d'abrutissement culturel à flatter cette
tendance à la facilité car c'est facile
d'écrire d'une façon phonétique que du
niveau en orthographe
eh bien on va vers une génération
d'illettrés ou d'analphabètes je crois
que il n'ya pas trop lieu de s'inquiéter
c'est plus un langage de connivence de
complicité social entre des gens qui
partagent ce code que quelque chose qui
pervertir est véritablement la langue
française et l'orthographe
le langage texto suscite les mêmes
craintes aujourd'hui que le verlan à
l'oral reste à savoir s'il restera ou
non un phénomène de mode passager
[Musique]